rhetoric is the the art to finding the
means of persuasion finding the ways to
be able to get people to do things and
this doesn't just go for communications
people or psychology or clinical science
business people need to pay attention to
this because
persuasion is part of motivation agathon
puts together this really nice speech
it's an argument
he says I'm going here's what we ought
to do and we give speeches about this
sort of thing here's what I'm going to
do and here's the first part of my
argument here's the second part of my
argument and now I'm going to open up
the floodgates and show off how you know
flashy I can be at the very end after
I've done the work after I've done the
here's argument a here's argument B
here's the points in favor of this you
you probably didn't catch that reading
through but that's the structure of it